cirque vraiment pas comme les autres et
j'emploie l'expression à dessein pas
d'animaux pas de nez rouge le cirque
plume est à la croisée des arts un
mélange d'acrobaties de danse de théâtre
et de poésie unique en son genre
le cirque plume a lancé une petite
révolution sous son chapiteau
créé en 1984 à besançon il a durablement
changer l'image du cirque en s'écartant
de certaines traditions c'est d'abord un
cirque sans animaux
on a coutume de dire que les animaux du
cirque plume cours librement dans les
rêves de ses spectateurs
les lions la fanfare et où je crois que
c'est ça a dû être bon en son temps mais
ce que je pense c'est que tout d'un coup
ça c'est un peut cristalliser en une
forme qui bouge plus et que ça dure et
on s'est dit le sacré c'est ça à la
rigueur les seuls bête que l'on dresse
au cirque plume sont des comédiens ou
des musiciens pour cette joyeuse famille
d'autodidacte c'est d'ailleurs par la
musique que tout a commencé
avant de s'appeler cirque plume c'était
un orchestre de rue une fanfare et c'est
donc la musique a été le point de
rencontre de tous ces gens j'essaie du
café théâtre de cirque de la danse plus
de la comédie dit cox albert roche
canada sont elles pas tellement les tic
est tombé dessus
ce mélange des genres une véritable
philosophie qui a permis au cirque plume
d'asseoir son succès trente six années
d'existence
onze spectacles originaux une
reconnaissance internationale et un état
d'esprit
qui n'a pas bougé avec le temps on a
cherché une rencontre poétique avec un
public n'a cherché étincelle qui peut se
passer entre une troupe et un public le
lien le plus vrai possible plus le plus
immédiat le plus éternel possible
pendant les spectacles c'est un autre
truc très créative c'est magnifique
c'est poétique c'est un grand poème au
fait que c'est superbe c'est un sujet
c'est un enchantement
aujourd'hui le cirque plume tire sa
révérence la troupe des fondateurs
gestionnaire depuis 1984 a vieilli et
décide tout simplement de prendre sa
retraite mais la compagnie sera à gagner
son pari celui d'imposer un renouveau
dans les arts du cirque
[Musique]